343 industries have revealed the pricing
info for halo 5s microtransactions so if
you don't want to grind multiplayer
matches to get to the top here so much
you'll have to shell out well you can
earn RP the old fashioned way you know
by playing the game you can also buy
silver and gold packs silver cuff 5,000
in-game RP or to real-world dollars
while gold will run you 10,000 RP or 3
bucks dave all three of said players
will get 7,500 RP to start and you can
expect to earn around 2,000 RP for every
war zone game on top of this Microsoft
are also offering a $25 war zone req
bundle which will deliver to premium
packs every week for a total of seven
weeks 3 pod 3 said some of the revenue
generated from micro transactions will
be funneled back into the halo World
Championship prize pool although they
haven't specified exactly how much 343
design director Kevin Franklin stress
that gamers won't be able to buy their
way into all the best stuff immediately
as you'll still need to level your
character in game to unlock the ability
to use higher level skier and vehicles
halo 5 launches on October 27 for Xbox
one learn is down in that comment
section where you think of the way halo
5 is handling micro transactions for all
the latest payload buy things and
everything else in gaming be sure to
stay tuned to gamespot